vous me demandez pas pourquoi je suis
devenu pompier j'imagine que tu as tes
raisons et qu'elles sont bonnes puisque
tu es là
[Musique]
tu quittes pas ton équipier des yeux
reste bien sûr le coup parce que des
fois on regarde le spectacle et c'est à
ce moment là qu'on s'est cramé
[Musique]
vous m'entendez ne quitte jamais le
théâtre des opérations avant d'avoir
tout vérifier
on y voyait pas bien sérieux elle a fait
le tour
elle a tout vérifié ouais je crois oui
ou non ouais ouais je crois
[Musique]
m
4 30 mètres on arrive eh bien regardez
moi d'amour
pratique tu as arrêté
et toi tu envie d'arrêter
le savoir si je pleure de temps en temps
ça
on est là pour les aider ils nous
crachent dessus matin c'est super dur
ouais sauf que le truc c'est que nous
n'avons l'os et éteindre le feu partout
on n'a pas le choix
tu rêvais d'être pompier comme beaucoup
de gamins
surtout le feu ça m'intéressait
quelqu'un
revers
[Musique]
c'est bien
capitaine le prenez pas mal que c'est
quand même super bon ouais c'est moi
de loin